ah
the klusty clab underwater narration
underwear asian
eight o'clock so long suckers closing
bikini bottoms premier eatery at 8 pm is
way too early what's that you say the
whole point of this episode is that they
eventually stay open later i know but i
once missed the peanut butter shake i
was craving because dairy queen closed
at eight and i'm the one handing out the
sins here
damn it i've got a hot date with a
little lady
and her name is clarinet being this
horny for your musical instrument as a
romantic partner
you just closed and you're already
sporting woodwind are you open
this guy and yes the store can be wrong
for being closed
and tom can be wrong for trying to get
food when the store is clearly closed
it's called nuance
learn it i'll have a krabby patty deluxe
and a double chili kelp fries
even if this fish is dumb enough to miss
the close sign is he dumb enough to miss
that he isn't at a drive-through window
straddling your employee you mean if we
stayed open later you'd give us your
money
greed mr squidward welcome to the night
shift scene does not contain a winkler a
keaton or a long
discount hamburglar crab burglar
considering it's closed why were this
many people just hanging around outside
krusty burger or whatever cartoon-based
krusty restaurant this is
in the first place wow
now we never have to stop working do you
even have the supplies to do this
expanding the business overnight also
means expanding your ordering krabby
patties don't just grow on trees you
know
or do they and then the sun will come up
how would anything living under the sea
have this deep an understanding of the
sun coming up
it'll be just like a sleepover only
we'll be sweaty and covered with grease
so just like a regular sleepover then
i'm chopping lettuce
at night chopping lettuce with a spatula
come on us bob
you know spatulas are only good for
flipping burgers swatting flies and
reaching that one itch you can't quite
get to right at the top of your crack
look at me i'm swapping the bathroom
spongebob
streptococcus pants not so huggable now
is he
also this is just terrible bathroom
design first are these barely there
sheets made by facebook
because they don't seemed at all
concerned with your privacy second wire
the sink and hand towel stations right
outside
the stalls with barely any room for
someone to exit while someone else is
cleaning their hands
and finally who puts a locker in a
bathroom right next to a
toilet you might as well just dip your
personal item straight in e coli and be
done with it
here give me a moment's piece and take
out the trash
trash that you were hanging out with
is it normal to have a bag of trash at
the ready under the counter like this
the sash ringing the trash singing
smash flinging this time's on for some
rhyme
he forgot the secret sauce sin he didn't
wash his hands
sin irregular portion
you mean like this or like this
or this or this
okay on one hand this show does make me
giggle sometimes but on the other hand i
don't understand why spongebob sleeves
don't fall off when he removes his arms
and if you don't know which hand i'm
going to go with welcome to your first
sins video experience
hope you stick around
legend says all these arms went off to
grow new spongebob bodies and start a
spongebob colony they created their own
government and were doing really well
until they traumatically collapsed
ironically it was because they couldn't
agree about the right to bear
arms can i have some ketchup not keeping
ketchup available at a separate
dispenser area i'm beginning to think
krusty krab may be a subpar eating
establishment eating yourself
and also apparently adding butter to
yourself and then eating yourself some
more this hand of elector scene is
all the disturbing you really want to
know
what are you sure you want to know
what what reality tv results shows
this show plays the do something till
it's not funny and then maybe gets funny
again card so much i think over half the
show exists in that part in the middle
where it's still not funny again
yet good thing the neon sign installers
and electricians needed to put up this
sign were available after 8 pm on a
tuesday
and work fast enough for this joke to
happen i'm just asking where do you draw
your line on cartoon physics
surely you have one right like even if
you want to just go with this bucket and
water going full menzel
chenoweth and defying gravity here then
why does spongebob even need the
plungers oh
boy 3am sleeping in tidy whities
quit killing your starseed and let your
boys breathe and honestly no matter what
genitals you're packing you need some
breathing space just consider this your
friendly pubic cervix announcement
what this is what i get for watching
spongebob sober aka
sober bobbing as in the tv sins
narrator's brain exploded at the end of
the episode because he'd forgotten the
dangers of sober
bobbing wait what
a sharpened stainless steel
hook where his right hand used to be
i've got a hot date with a little lady
and one time at band camp are you open
here's your sign
for the krusty krab and so adorned the
hopeless athenians do the unthinkable
they attack most people just call him
the
hat look if he was dying he wouldn't
bother to carve
ugg can i have a job application
i brought my own spatula and what better
way to say i love you than with a gift
of a spatula